if you fail
it will be a massacre let's talk about
this for a minute why
that would be the whole film I'm serious
because you know III wrote on the front
page of the script this movie is written
and designed to be one shot one
continuous shot and I send it to him and
I said I warned you you know you got to
get get past the first page and read it
and I think you know he was worried when
he first read it probably you didn't
want it to be a gimmick you know but I
was convinced it wasn't and that there
was a reason there was a story reason to
do it but the big challenge was you know
to divorce how difficult it was and
tried to get to what we actually wanted
the camera to do and Express in every
moment because we couldn't cut and so we
had to construct this dance between the
actors the camera and the landscape
which is constantly moving through and
different environments and we talked for
months and months about it you know
almost non-stop and rehearsed and talked
and constructed things and talked
practice and you know all this stuff and
so when we came to shoot it it wasn't
exactly easy but it was easier than I
think we both imagined but it was
because we had spoken so much about it
and we you know Rogers a job of
engineering I'm just a lone engineer you
know because we were shooting on wires
on cranes on backs of vehicles on
motorbikes handheld constructing rigs
that have never been invented before and
even a camera a camera body by Harry
that didn't exist until this movie it
because we had to get it into such tight
spaces down holes and into dugouts and
so it was an engineering challenge as
much as anything else but it was a lot
of fun - your brother
oh well I suppose had always wanted to
in an ideal world you know I'd always
wanted to be the one of those guys who
can sit down and write the movie I
wanted to make but I never felt
motivated to do it partly because I'm
not a I didn't think I was a great
writer and you when you're being offered
scripts by people who are better than
you you should do those instead so but
the Bond experience gave me the courage
to sit down in a room and write on my
own because I'd been in the room with
the writers developing both those movies
from scratch there was nothing so I
wasn't unfamiliar with a blank page and
that it was the first time really I felt
that and then also we did a the
beginning of Spectre was a long
eight-minute shot and that gave me a
kind of flavor of what might be like to
make a whole movie like that I mean and
I was excited by that idea and then when
I came to do it there was this story
that I wanted to tell which was a story
based on the stories my grandfather told
me of the first world war and and that
gave it a personal dimension I felt like
it was it was my family story in a way
so that I should I should you know get
off my butt and write something myself
[Music]
I auditioned hundreds of young actors
but like first of all I wanted young men
and I wanted kind of the audience to
have a new relationship with them I
didn't want them to know where they're
gonna live or die and I wanted it to
feel I suppose like a - there were just
two amongst two million you know not
special in any particular way so that
was that and then you know I wanted a
old fashioned dignified quite internal
what English man first Cofield and that
was George and I wanted someone chattier
and funnier and more vulnerable and
younger and less experienced for Blake
and I wanted that unlikely friendship to
feel real so that's that's why I went
for the two of them and they were great
and they became friends off-camera and
that was also helpful there's only one
way this ends
Last Man Standing
I don't think you ever know kind of what
the final piece will be I just wanted to
be involved because the first thing I
heard about it was Sam you know the
first the audition it was a first world
war piece by Sam Mendes and so
immediately knowin Sam's working you
know invoke theater and film just wanted
to be involved and then on the second
audition then that there so then it was
reading the to audition scenes which
were just written so beautifully which
was the script written by Christian Sam
and then meeting Sam and the way he
explained this one-shop nature of how we
were going to do it and what that would
mean we were Hearst for six months
beforehand just being involved and
having an understanding of all aspects
of the filmmaking process for so long
before I just wanted to just wanted to
be a part of it and I think that the
undertaking was so great the only way to
do it was just to take one step at a
time
and build it layer by layer rather than
get over awed by the you know the idea
of the final piece pretty much what
George said it was really you know it
was really exciting to work with Sam and
knowing that he was sort of got to lead
the ship and and welcome over the bar
it's a lot Sam you know he's got such a
clear crystal clear vision of the
characters you know he know the
character just as well as me and he also
wrote the script with Christie so having
that as a director that sort of guiding
you is very comforting as an actor
[Music]
it is different it was raw and genuine
but at the same time very well I mean we
had to be so specific in what we were
doing it was a choreographed dance
everything we were doing but everything
was just so realistic and so immersive
like Dennis Gassner the production
designer did such a brilliant job in
bringing those trenches in those sets to
life it never felt like we were walking
on say it felt like we were walking you
know in the trenches and that's what was
great about it so that really did allow
you you know to just lose yourself in
the same and the whole one-take aspect
you know you can do the same for 9
minutes long and just forget you making
a film and and that's where it comes in
where it's just the raw honest genuine
performance rather than acting you know
there's there's a sequence I've talked
about a lot in in no-man's land when the
camera sort comes down to black and sky
fields fate and our failure just
slipping everywhere and that's not us
acting that we're slipping that's
genuine we're trying to walk in the mud
so a lot of it really was just reacting
to how the characters would react in
that situation and just be real that it
yeah I think she's one of the loveliest
things was just them Sam would often be
a bit like throw it away you know just
just talk just and also take pauses as
well like that
um um when we first came to rehearse a
section at the front line and obviously
we kind of the lines of fresh in our
head so you just want to kind of get
through them and you said no just think
about what they're thinking about
they're probably got a process this
mission they've just been given it's
just walk in silence for a bit mm-hmm
and when you feel like talking start
talking you know and that thing of you
know and we had to plot those distance
and eventually that distance became
specific but just the kind of naturalism
that he encouraged enough in the way
that in a normal conversation things go
quiet hmm and you think about something
else and then you and it was just and
also just play at the camera was always
there and never you're never offering it
sort of like you might on stage or
something like that you were just yeah
just focus on natural it's very lived
hmm
I mean they're completely different
things I may not get this thing called
into the badlands and I to fight with
two swords and I only did like a nine
day boat camp for that but you know
really how he was doing eight-hour days
trying to learn you know how to fight
with swords and I did pretty much all my
own stunts in that but that was
completely different you know that that
was you know that my character would cut
himself in and it suddenly turned into
like this superpower would I call it
dark chain he was pretty much
indestructible whereas this is you know
they're not superheroes they're just
real men they're just British soldiers
that don't they can't fly and they can't
you know willed knifes like castor curly
just you know they're just men and the
thing is this is a real very real story
a very human story it's not necessarily
a World War one film it's not an
educational war film it's just a very
simple story really told on a very human
level and they've got so different
projects if you don't get there in time
[Music]
we will lose 1,600 men your brother
among them good luck
I am so Sam is a delight to work with
he's very open he's very honest he's
very generous I'm he's the kind of
collaborator that you don't mind looking
stupid in front of which is so important
because you can if you can't get through
the kind of stage where you're pitching
stupid ideas you don't get to the stage
where you end up with you know good
ideas I'm but the process for this film
was really different from anything else
I've written before I knew before we
even sat down and what the treatment
that it was going to be one short and it
was going to be a story in real time so
you have to completely write retrain
your brain how to write that because
usually a script is like a map you know
you're just trying to get a lot of
people to a place where they can then
have a finished film but this script had
to be the destination it had to be the
finished film when you read it you had
to kind of see it in your head and also
because we wrote it on spec we don't
even know if it was gonna work or not so
we wrote it we sat down and started this
just like working in a prayer like maybe
or working it would be cool and if it
doesn't that's fine like you know we've
done six months unpaid work which is a
bit of a bummer if you've got a mortgage
which I do um but no very luckily Sam
and I together like muddled through got
it to the stage we were really happy
with it and then all these other
brilliant people came on board and you
end up with 1917
well I mean I was really involved in the
process from like well not the
conception if I do but the basically
putting the idea on paper all the way
through to last week or this week even
I'm still involved I'm it was really
amazing to be part of that because the
nature of the script there's no final it
like not in a traditional sense and you
know the edits called the final rewrite
for a reason because you can do anything
you want in the edit suite I'm and so I
had to be on set because whatever we
recorded on say that day would go
straight into the film and sometimes
dialogue wouldn't work or sometimes
there was too much dialogue or sometimes
you know there was a change or and
actually do something in a certain way
and so it was basically my job to then
tweak the script before they shoot it
and that so we would rehearse in the
morning usually so I turn up very early
which was horrendous for me zerator I'm
like I'm like I'll get outta bed about
9:00 and they're like we'll see you at
7:00 I was like why so I would get up
early I would be on set we would we
would run a rehearsal we run a technical
rehearsal then went after that and then
we would like keep kind of like refining
and refining because it was all a dance
between the actors and the camera and
the set design I am so there would be I
mean there was times in the mornings
where Sam was like can we take some more
Trench and they would that was how
amazing this it was like they had the
ability to literally tunnel which is
fairly niche I am and then we would
start to go for takes and even during
the take sometimes we would be refining
and refining until until Sam was happy
until we got it right I am but there was
months or a hair source before we
actually sat down and short as well
which I was massively involved and I
which was a dream come true
it's so rare do you get you as a writer
be involved in the process where they
are fixing the dialogue in the actors
mouths I am and to work with George and
Dean who are both so spectacularly
talented brought so much those
characters on the page for us
I am the allowed everything to just be
better
no man's land was particularly difficult
just because the terrain itself was
almost unnavigable like you couldn't get
across I almost took George makyo
falling am I sunk into mines and it was
so it was it was tough just from a
purely physical sense for everyone
especially for George and ending Charles
I mean what they had to do and you see
it you know in the film it looks at bat
it looks hard but they probably had to
do it 40 50 times a day because by the
time you factor in the technical
rehearsals the takes everything like
that you know there was again and again
and again and that mud was like I see it
was like oil you couldn't stand on it
I'm so that was really hard but then
every day we sort of remind ourselves
that that we're just making a film that
that man for real like we're earlier for
three weeks men were in France for three
and a half years and they were getting
sure do you know I mean and they were
like fighting for their life so even
though it was difficult there was always
that kind of reminder in your head of
like well what we're doing is just like
a tiny percentage 1% half a percent of
what these men went through I'm which I
gave everyone a sort of sense of respect
I'm worried that I will be murdered and
that there may be a sniper if I tell you
anything about it what I can tell you is
that in its short rate after 1917 I was
on the set for that as well I was blown
away by the talent and skill of Anna and
ma and Thomas McKenzie who's just unreal
edgar skills and i've seen i've seen a
bits of it i'm cut together I've seen
some of the sequences I'm really really
proud of it I can't wait for the world
to see is everything you want from an
Edgar Wright movie and and it's but it's
still a bit different from his usual so
that that's why I can see
[Music]